dhoklas bike shares and electric
scooters are gaining popularity in the
u.s. these modern modes of
transportation that you can rent with
apps are also causing controversy at
least 53 cities now operate bike share
programs and one more is launching in
Chicago the services are transforming
the daily routine for many commuters but
also becoming a hassle for local
governments Kris Van Cleave is in
Washington one of the first cities to
have what some critics call litter bikes
Chris good morning good morning these
scooters and bikes are likely a case of
technology out outpacing the laws but
they are zipping across cities
coast-to-coast and you know they're
inexpensive and they're aimed at the
last mile or so of your commute however
they are bringing out the worst in some
people you can see why the electric
scooters and dhoklas bikes have earned
the nickname litter bikes people can and
are leaving them just about anywhere in
the middle of a busy walkway on the
National Mall up a tree in Seattle on
the shoulder of a highway in Virginia or
in the water
this man was arrested after throwing one
onto the tracks in front of a DC metro
train what's the biggest challenge
operating in a city and it like a dense
city educating the public on appropriate
parking parking parking parking you know
we just need to remind people that they
need to park these bikes as they would
with any other responsible use product
maggie Gendron from line bike which
operates in more than 50 cities says
riders tend to learn the proper
etiquette quickly and the technology is
changing how people get around it's
making movement for short distances more
convenient and allowing people to not
have to rely on a car to get around 40
percent of our rides started and ended
at other transit stops riders find them
with an app on their phone and can ride
for as little as $1 the scooters can hit
speeds of up to 15 miles an hour
riders are encouraged to wear helmets
use bike lanes and avoid pedestrian
filled sidewalks I really like the the
doclist ones you can just drop off
wherever and hopefully find one when you
need one most established bike share
programs typically use docking stations
they can cost cities millions to install
and
maintain the Dhokla spikes are
privately-owned require no taxpayer
dollars and can be left anywhere I just
hate when they're scattered all over the
sidewalks in San Francisco that's become
a problem
while the city rolls out a permitting
plan cease and desist letters were sent
to three companies giving them until
today to submit plans to satisfy state
and local requirements the companies say
they will work with the city people are
picking them up riding them on the
streets and sidewalks impeding
pedestrian traffic sort of and then
parking them in the middle of the street
on the sidewalk in doorways really
impeding people's progress and walking
on the sidewalk or getting in out of
buildings and it's just creating a real
public nuisance coronado near san diego
also deemed them a public nuisance they
throw them on the ground they've got the
green ones and the orange ones and it's
basically litter
after impounding at least 55 of the
scooters Austin Texas passed an
ordinance Friday finding companies
without proper permits up to $200 per
bike or scooter but with riders they are
popular in the nation's capital seven
companies are offering dhoklas bikes or
scooters
they are zipping around town with
increasing frequency the city says it's
test period has sparked tremendous
feedback most of it positive John Ruiz
is a fan my walk is about 16 17 minutes
on the scooter I think it's like six to
eight minutes so it's a lot faster the
companies say they have technology in
the app to identify people who are
parking like jerks and actually they say
they can penalize those folks if fines
become a reality now the companies are
also pledging to grow responsibly so
they don't flood cities with these
devices pick them up every night and in
some cases they are sharing revenue with
cities to increase infrastructure like
bike lanes John Kriss thinks I like that
app for people who park like jerks to go
across all vehicles one of these being a
jerk app yes oh that's an important math
these days